par ces belles journées d'automne nous
vous proposons un voyage au pays de born
le pays de born est une contrée qui
s'étendent le long de la côte dans la
moitié septentrionale du département des
landes réputé pour ses nombreux lacs et
étangs du dos par la route nationale 6
126 nous atteignons le lac d'aureilhan
havre de paix et de tranquillité
le lac est ceint d'une ceinture de
rideau de roseaux où les voiliers
peuvent s'amuser tout à loisir avec le
vent les pins de la forêt landaise aime
à se mirer dans les eaux calmes de
l'étendue zardi forges
seul le clapot des canaux vient troubler
la quiétude des nénuphars
lorsque l'on se promène dans la forêt il
n'est pas rare de rencontrer un bouvier
qui se déplace à pas lents et compter
avec son attelage
en suivant le courant de mimizan on
découvre une vallée riche et industriel
qui se dorent au soleil
cette dune boisée de pain qui abrite à
leur pied une immense plage de sable
blanc ou vient battre la mer
c'est contis plage où se dresse
fièrement le seul phare de la côte
landaise
bon